[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco
sobre parís sobre la capital de francia
que se proyecta como la gran capital del
arte en la europa posterior al break sip
y la post pandemia con la renovación de
varios de sus grandes centros culturales
y la atracción de galerías nos acompañan
en este estudio cantuta quirós curadora
y profesora en la escuela de
arquitectura de nantes bienvenida
cantuta y édgar cherubini es periodista
independiente bienvenido de édgar
bienvenido a todo gabriela bravo
corresponsal en parís de radio
cooperativa de chile bienvenida a
gabriela mucho gusto
parís epicentro de las artes en la
europa del post ver éxito hoy en en
primera plana
el paisaje museístico de parís se
encuentra en plena transformación con
renovaciones de gran magnitud que
durarán años como las del centro georges
pompidou o las del grand palais a esto
hay que añadir la llegada a la capital
francesa de variadas colecciones y de
galerías apoyadas por fundaciones y es
que en la europa del post break sit
parís puede aprovechar para ser de nuevo
la capital artística de las vanguardias
como lo fue a principios de siglo la
entrada en vigor del break si favorece
los intereses de la capital francesa
frente a londres que hasta 2019
acumulaba más del 60 por ciento de las
transacciones del sector del arte en
europa puede volver a ser país la
capital de las vanguardias ahora se lo
planteo a nuestros invitados antes
repasemos algunas portadas de prensa
diario le figaro centro pompidou un
cierre con duras consecuencias aunque
las obras dice el rotativo eran
inevitables para este edificio
emblemático el diario 'el país' la nueva
edad dorada del arte en parís dice en
uno de sus artículos en las páginas de
cultura aquí en francia la revista
especializada bossa art se preguntaba en
su pasado número de octubre por qué la
moda pasional
los museos en este momento una relación
que tiene que ver mucho con parís y que
va a estar muy presente seguro en la
perspectiva que vamos a dar hoy en el
programa pero lo primero de todo notan
que hay un optimismo latente y cultural
artístico ante el panorama de
transformación que se abre en parís en
los próximos años cantuta sí yo creo que
hay una conversé con vejer ciencia de
factores que pueden dar indicios de
optimismo por ejemplo esta pasada semana
hubo una feria de arte que se tuvo en
real feria de arte contemporáneo
africano
poniendo parís en un modo muy distinto
de lo que vemos desde meses de depresión
también con el break city parís se
recupera competencia con los derechos de
aduana por ejemplo poniéndose en una
posición nada interesante en el mercado
del arte
lo que mencionabas también alrededor de
las renovaciones de museos también es
son índices que hay un dinamismo en
parís importante la cuestión para mí es
es cual giro está tomando parís ahora y
como sus museos se van a poder
posicionar también como espacios
democráticos como espacios de
emancipación y eso es otra cuestión y
pues luego en una segunda ronda vamos a
tratar ese giro tan interesante lo
dejamos ahí para escuchar también a
édgar y a gabriel a édgar un optimismo
latente podríamos hablar de ello todos
apostamos a ese optimismo lógicamente
estamos dentro del mundo del arte y de
alguna manera estamos apostando tenemos
la esperanza de que al término de esta
crisis
y podamos retomar aunque sea como dicen
algunos una normalidad anormal pero
retomar la verdad estoy hablando de
museos galerías ferias etc pero hay que
hay que tener mucha prudencia también
porque en este momento lo único que de
los cuales estamos seguros es de que
vivimos en una gran incertidumbre y
sobre todo francia en francia que tiene
una caída del pib de 8%
una barbaridad es la peor recesión
después de la guerra
y el mundo del arte ya venía con sus
fallas vamos a llamarla así francia
venía mermando en en su importancia
dentro del mercado global del arte tan
ejército acaba de mencionar inglaterra
tenía el 60 por ciento de esa torta eeuu
tener 40 por ciento verdad este francés
tenía el 2 por ciento en el 2019 o sea
es una realidad o no estoy siendo
pesimista ni estoy siendo digamos
diciendo lo contrario a todo lo que
queremos apostar de parís como capital
del arte pero la recuperación verdad
este va a ser difícil la vamos a tener
que todos ayudar o sea lo privado lo
público lo institucional tenemos que
ayudar a ese recuperó ahora estoy
totalmente de acuerdo en que tenemos que
rehacer
volverá a ser la capital del arte es un
programa del que estamos hablando de
perspectivas estamos hablando a futuro
por tener un poco de esperanza en estos
tiempos pero como dice édgar la única
seguridad aunque es un paradójico que
tenemos ahora mismo es la incertidumbre
no gabriela vamos a la si ponemos un
poco de optimismo y optimismo lo están
poniendo los artistas y el público
porque lo que hemos visto hoy es que una
vez que los museos se cerraron lo único
que ha permaneció abierto son las
galerías y la gente fue en masa a poder
encontrarse con este pequeño el espacio
de arte que es lo que está quedando en
estos momentos entonces en la creación
artística sigue en boga no ha parado y
han encontrado nuevos canales para
expresarse y el público vemos que está
presente dice estamos aquí nosotros
queremos seguir consumiendo consumiendo
si se puede hablar así
pero como lo hemos dicho todos estamos a
la espera estamos en pausa pero esta
pausa no es una pausa de quedarnos
quietos sino es seguir produciendo
seguir creando y yo estoy segurísima que
vamos a ver muchas obras que van a salir
de esta gran crisis que ha sido esta
pandemia mundial hay varios indicios que
apuntan a esta teoría de que parís
vuelva a ser una capital de vanguardias
en la post pandemia para empezar en este
2021 siete museos parisinos reabren sus
puertas en cuanto la pandemia lo permita
cómo va a ser este arranque de
inauguraciones cantuta bueno para mí son
también índices de la importancia
cada vez más de las fundaciones privadas
porque va a abrirla
fundación que también sucederá a bolsa
de comercio sí y en lugares
patrimoniales islas
exacto y mis de la marina entonces para
mí son más índices de una relación muy
patrimonial a la ciudad de parís muy
histórica
y también el giro me parece que se
podría decir un poco neoliberal de las
políticas culturales en parís con las
fundaciones privadas hubo también
anteriormente la fundación youtube
y entonces es una visión del museo para
mí muy global y no mucho de
experimentación de creación
contemporánea
cuando hablabas antes del giro
democrático de referirse a esa
contraposición entre esa perspectiva
asociada a grandes marcas espónsores y
el giro más experimental giro
democrático relacionado con lo más
experimental o más para mí en la
cuestión es cuál
a quién se dirige el museo y como
considera el público es un consumidor es
un turista y así para mí todas estas
aperturas son muy vinculados vinculadas
a esta visión de del público como
turista y como el museo como una marca
el museo global que siempre se repite
con el mismo esquema una arquitecta
estar y una escenografía muy
espectacular
me parece que otra posición podría hacer
de pensar el museo como el lugar donde
se puede pensar una esfera pública y eso
es para édgar lo que tú estás diciendo
me parece muy interesante y hay que
tomar en cuenta un factor que es lo
acaba de mencionar el turismo en francia
recibe al año 86 millones de personas de
visitantes de esos 86 millones de
visitantes que recibe francia
fundamentalmente parís
9 millones acudieron al club en el año
2010 y 99 millones de personas 3
millones al pompidou 2 millones al 12
etcétera ósea
bienvenida a la esfera privada que está
siendo de sponsor de esos pequeños
museos porque son carnavales una
maravilla del museo de uno de mis
favoritos pero museo pequeño o sea es un
museo de patrimonio bastante reducido
igual que los que acabas de mencionar
hablantes pueden convivir quiera no esa
parte de sponsor privado y la parte más
experimental o la perspectiva que estaba
haciendo cantuta es decir pueden
convivir en el mismo plano porque al
mismo tiempo efectivamente la ciudad
también vive del turismo y ser eso
absolutamente y ese es el nicho vamos a
llamarlo así lo han percibido las
grandes casas de subasta que mueven
evidentemente a los grandes
coleccionistas y a los grandes a las
grandes firmas verdad y yo creo que es
parte de ese eso que tú llamas optimismo
que yo lo abordó con mucha prudencia
pero que ojos que no han puesto a que
esto sea así que sea una realidad
la llegada a parís de firmas importantes
como david schwimmer o house en wire es
parte de esto que carlos llama optimismo
que llamamos todos esperanza de que va a
haber una renovación un reinicio de la
capital del arte que ha sido siempre
parís que fue ojo que fue hace 10 años
20 años que fue lo mencionaste al
comienzo en cuando los artistas acudían
a san german o sea fue la capital del
arte sigue siendo para nosotros la
capital del arte y hay que inyectarle
lógicamente capital a todo esto una
buena noticia dentro de esta
incertidumbre es que el estado francés
va a inyectar 3800 millones de euros
ámbito cultural artístico patrimonial o
sea es una cantidad inédita en francia
alemania no se queda atrás 2.500
millones verdad este eeuu es la que
estaba un poco en retraso porque ha
tenido una pérdida en el sector cultural
cultural de 55.000 millones de dólares
con esta crisis pero estos son buenas
estas son buenas noticias de que vamos
avanzando y vamos a recuperarnos
édgar guardamos algún argumento para
vuelta de pausa y enseguida les pregunto
por muchas cosas entre otras
si el break si puede favorecer a parís
artísticamente lo vemos a vuelta de
pausa hasta ahora
[Música]
a
la canciller alemana angela merkel
reconoció que hay ansias de reapertura
en alemania en especial después de dos
meses de restricciones estrictas y un
paso concreto hacia la reapertura se dio
esta semana con el regreso a clases en
la mayoría de las regiones de alemania y
en particular para los alumnos más
jóvenes en escuelas de primaria o en
guarderías el regreso se da por supuesto
bajo estrictas medidas de higiene con
medidas como la reducción en el número
de alumnos por clase o la rotación entre
la virtualidad y la presencialidad para
así evitar al máximo los posibles
contactos también se le dará más
prioridad la vacunación de los
profesores aunque algunos ven este
regreso a clases con escepticismo pues
consideran que puede llevar a que
aumenten las infecciones de nuevo la
mayoría de los alemanes apoyan este
regreso progresivo a la presencialidad y
de hecho según una encuesta de mediados
de este mes el 58% de los alemanes ve
esta medida con buenos ojos
[Música]
más de un millón de estudiantes de
distintos ciclos se encuentran en la
incertidumbre sobre el inicio oficial de
las clases que según el ministerio de
educación y cultura está previsto para
el próximo martes 2 de marzo aquí en
paraguay sin embargo los principales
gremios docentes del país anunciaron
para ese mismo día una serie de
movilizaciones y protestas a nivel
nacional debido principalmente a dos
razones la número uno es que según dicen
no están garantizadas las condiciones
que aseguren la salud del cuerpo docente
ni de los estudiantes y además más de
400 establecimientos escolares no
estarían en condiciones edilicias para
poder ingresar a esos lugares así que la
situación aquí es de incertidumbre y
sabremos cuál va a ser la situación la
próxima semana
[Música]
después de una notable reducción en el
número de casos diarios de kobe 19
sudáfrica ha reabierto los colegios y
esto se da después de varias semanas de
que la reapertura se hubiera postergado
dado que el país se encontraba en plena
segunda ola de la pandemia
sudáfrica es un país que ha perdido más
de mil maestros en el último año y por
eso en esta ocasión se ha hecho especial
énfasis en que la reapertura cuente con
las medidas de bioseguridad adecuadas
sin embargo un estudio a nivel nacional
ha determinado que menos del 40% de las
escuelas se encuentran preparadas para
esta reapertura y muchas de ellas alegan
que no cuentan con los equipos de
protección necesarios para reactivar
plenamente sus actividades por otra
parte el sistema educativo enfrenta
también un problema adicional y es el
desafío que van a tener miles de
estudiantes que dados los cierres han
tenido retrasos en muy grandes en el
currículum académico y esto afecta sobre
todo a aquellos estudiantes que no
cuentan con la tecnología o los medios
necesarios para la educación virtual
[Música]
continuamos aquí en primera plana hoy
hablando de parís como epicentro de las
artes en la europa post break si lo
hacemos con cantuta quirot curadora y
profesora en la escuela de arquitectura
de nantes gabriela bravo corresponsal en
parís de radio cooperativa de chile y
édgar querubín y periodista
independiente bueno estábamos hablando
antes de la pausa les quería preguntar
por la entrada en vigor del break sheet
que sin duda puede favorecer los
intereses de la capital francesa que
hasta 2019
londres acumulaba más del 60 por ciento
de las transacciones de arte en europa
el break sheet gabriela puede acabar
siendo una buena noticia una
consecuencia positiva para el parís de
las artes yo creo que esto puede tener
dos ramificaciones por un lado está todo
lo que es el espectáculo vivo el ballet
ópera todo lo que son los conciertos
el break sit es un golpe muy duro para
el reino unido en este sentido ya que al
salir de la comunidad europea ellos van
a tener que gastar más dinero en visas
en visas de trabajo en una toda una
burocracia que antes se les daba por
estar dentro de la unión europea no
necesitaban todo eso entonces sus obras
podían internación internacionalizarse
de manera más fácil entonces parís
podría podría tomar este nicho que deja
que deja un poco libre el reino unido
donde todas estas obras de con público
podría ser parís el corazón para que
estas obras se pudieran
internacionalizar y por otro lado la
otra rama es el mercado del arte
y esto podría beneficiar el break si
podría beneficiar
yo creo al reino unido debido a que
ellos pueden poner ahora sus propias
reglas
es decir si ellos no quieren poner
ningún impuesto a las obras y hacer que
el mercado de las obras de arte se
desarrolla en el reino unido- ellos van
a tener muchísima más libertad que lo
que puede tener francia que está
sometido a la reglamentación europea
algo que pasa de gestión de otros campos
también no sé si queréis añadir algo
sobre el break city cantuta web gar
partiendo un poco lo que has dicho el
complemento es el hecho de que david
schwimmer una de las más importantes
galerías mundiales en este momento
que además se adelantó a esta situación
esta crisis de beats winner tiene un
biberón
maravilloso desde el año 2000 desde el
año 2017 ya se adelantó a lo que ahora
están tratando de adaptarse muchas
galerías de buscar internet poner un
libro en internet o sea él estaba
digamos convencido de que parte de él
de hacer arte se se trasladaría a las
redes sociales es un hombre de avanzada
un hombre digamos con una mentalidad y
de innovación yo tuve la oportunidad la
gran oportunidad hace dos meses de
participar en un coloquio donde estaba
él estaba el presidente de abbas él y
estaban tres una curadora inglesa y un
economista o sea analizando justamente
esto que estamos hoy
conversando verdad éste debe swinger
dijo declaró que él su galería tiene
galerías en cinco continentes verdad y
todas
avanza maravillosamente cuando el las
galerías francesas para tomar el ejemplo
de francia este una de cada tres están
cerrando y hay que tomar en
consideración todos estos hechos verdad
él se muda a parís porque dice lo que tú
acabas de decir yo tengo mi galería en
londres pero es una galería para
inglaterra
yo soy europeo me siento europeo pienso
como un europeo y por eso voy a tener
una galería en parís o sea que eso me
pareció una declaración maravillosa
recogió el financial times y una
cantidad de diarios esos son un poco
como se plasma el break sheet en el
mundo del arte vamos a seguir avanzando
porque tenemos una serie de renovaciones
no sé si ponerle el adjetivo de
faraónicas o no ahora que me lo diga es
cantuta sobre todo está hablando de
dedos que están a la vuelta de una ya
está en marcha y la otra va a empezar ya
muy pronto de dos instituciones
colosales aquí en parís una es el grand
palais y otra el centro georges pompidou
que destacaríamos the stars
innovaciones incluso creo que en su
momento se planteó que estas
renovaciones fueran aún mas faraónicas y
sus responsables creo que el último que
lo ha dicho en prensa ha sido el del
grand palais ha dicho que se siente
aliviado por tener presupuestos menos
descontrolados y más adaptados a la
sostenibilidad que me parece un tema
clave aquí de estas renovaciones campus
sí sí en el proyecto inicial en
compañera más más importante y al final
al final las excavaciones la destrucción
del edificio va a ser menos importante
con una atención ecológica también
a la cualidad de energética de la del
edificio y también el entorno
urbanístico y paisajístico de los
jardines de los campos elíseos entonces
sí entonces va a ser pensado de esa
forma y para pompidou también es una
serie de renovación que también tiene
que poner a normas medioambientales
también
me gustaría
estas renovaciones por lo menos mi forma
de ver responden también a un cambio
societal es decir por ejemplo el museo
pompidou para sacar el asbesto todo esto
que fue la construcción de toda la
europa que se construyó encima de los
textos resulta que ahora nos damos
cuenta que nos hace mal también van a
ser entradas para personas con
discapacidad van a hacer una renovación
de la climatización que va a ser más
ecológica entonces estos museos un museo
en nuestra cabeza siempre es algo fijo
que muestra cosas que ya han pasado
estos museos se están adaptando a esta
nueva sociedad que busca más integración
que busca poner también en el centro la
ecología y en este sentido yo creo que
que están a la cabeza de un movimiento
también ciudadano están acompañándolo en
la medida de lo posible estos museos de
arte contemporáneo el otro factor
esencial del que hoy queremos hablar son
los puentes entre el sector de lujo y el
arte
que se ven como en pocas partes aquí en
la capital francesa les pregunto enviar
el lujo se ha convertido en un vector
fundamental para la industria cultural y
más aquí en parís solo tienes que
analizar el mercado global del arte y te
das cuenta que hay un grupo de
individuos un segmento un sector de los
individuos de todas las sociedades que
han considerado que invertir en arte es
mejor que invertir en la bolsa de
valores verdad eso es primero que nada y
vemos entonces o no estoy diciendo que
no aprecien una buena escultura o una
buena pintura sino que sencillamente se
dan cuenta que la dentro de esta gran
incertidumbre que vivimos y sobre todo
las bolsas de valores que por cierto se
han mantenido estables en dentro de la
crisis ellos prefieren invertir en obras
de arte y vemos entonces cómo hace
dos meses apenas o menos de dos meses
este software se ha vendido el
maravilloso tríptico de francis bacon a
un coleccionista privado en 84 millones
de euros así en medio de la crisis en
medio de la pandemia m lo que quiero
decir con esto es que ese segmento que
van aa basel con entrada privilegiada
que van a base en suiza a base en miami
a base en hong kong movilizándose en su
jet privados verdad y que tienen el
privilegio de poder hacerlo este son
esos los que de alguna manera están
salvando el mercado del arte en esta
crisis veamos la otra cara por ejemplo
se puede ver en barrios de parís anne ya
mandé en su día el epicentro literario
con los cafés con sas con simon de
beauvoir etcétera ahora está lleno de
marcas de lujo pasa también en el barrio
del mare es la otra cara del lujo que
asociado al capitalismo no sé si puede
hacer qué
de un buen mecenas pero también de
desvirtuado ahora al mismo tiempo de
ciertos lugares como ven esta dicotomía
entre mecenas y barrios que pueden
acabar estando desvirtuados a mí me
parece que el lujo y el arte son un poco
van van de la mano no hay que ver
solamente acá en francia que dos de las
fortunas más grandes que han hecho
fortuna en el lujo como espino y oro
ellos también son coleccionistas de arte
son personas que han hecho fundaciones
museos y son
sin embargo que que es para mí que es lo
que yo me me pregunto es por ejemplo el
lujo solo muestra un éxito financiero un
éxito monetario es decir una joya un
auto algo de lujo cualquiera puede tener
acceso sin embargo el arte representa un
es un capital simbólico no todos no
todas las personas que tienen dinero
tienen acceso a el arte porque esto no
es no es llegar a decir un precio bueno
cuánto vale esto yo lo compro hay que
saber hay que estar
hay que ser instruido es porque también
te pueden timar es decir te ponen un
cuadro muy bonito si tú no sabes tú tú
no tienes acceso a saber un precio
porque no es como comprar un reloj de
marca
yo quería poner por ejemplo el ejemplo
hay gente que tiene mucho dinero como
los futbolistas y no es por eso que
ellos invierten en el mercado del arte
porque hay que saber hay que hay que ser
introducido en eso es un poco como una
pesca milagrosa hay que conocer las
tendencias hay que ver hacia dónde va el
mercado y no es solamente una cosa de
dinero también hay un componente
emocional y cultural muy fuerte cantuta
no es algo que añadir a esto sí bueno lo
que todavía se también el arte como como
herramienta de distinción social
sí sí y bueno cuando hablamos de salón
han depredado la gentrificación es muy
antigua hace mucho tiempo que se llama
ya no es digamos que si el lujo la
pregunta es el lujo puede acelerar ese
proceso sí pero hoy ya creo que ya desde
mucho tiempo están ramón ya no es un
barrio de creación de pensamiento o son
más vestigios o ruinas de un pasado
experencia y está muy de acuerdo contigo
y ha dejado ha perdido esa aura de ese
espíritu de lo que fue un cartel
cultural artístico de poetas de
literatos de escritores de pintores
verdad que la unesco ha debido a
declarar patrimonio cultural de la
humanidad ese cartel nunca lo hizo
verdad y vemos entonces y tienes toda la
razón como se han ido destruyendo
famosos visto o sea que donde cuando
cuando uno entraba sabía que había había
estado ahí hemingway había estado
también o había estado este picasso
verdad no han transformado esos visto
que eran de madera y vidrio en plástico
y aluminio no me queda más tiempo
muchísimas gracias a los tres por
haberme acompañado hoy siento cortarle
pero es que nos vamos ya de tiempo ha
sido un placer esta perspectiva del arte
a todos ustedes muchísimas gracias y
hasta la próxima semana en primera plana